what is the message to the world with
black panther I think the message is
that is that it that it works to have
you know black cast do not make any
decisions based on money none it's the
worst way to make a decision there's no
substitute for becoming an expert in
being the best at your craft
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out onto the world now this is a new
series called black excellence I don't
pretend to know what it's like growing
up as a black man in America but I do
believe that you can support one
community without putting another
community down so my aim with this
series is to shine a light on excellence
in the black community I hope you enjoy
so let's kick things off with rule
number one prove them wrong with
Chadwick Boseman
what is the message to the world with
Black Panther I think the message is
that is that it that it works to have
you know black cast
[Applause]
it works that I that our stories can
resonate not just in this country but
throughout the world we've been on a
tour showing the movie we went to South
Korea just before the Olympics came and
they're exciting we were like the
Beatles in London so it's that that that
that uh idea that a black movie can't
travel that's that's been said very
often when when Studios talk about
funding movies they will make that
statement that you know we don't sell
overseas yeah
it's the exact opposite it seems to be
rule number two envision a greater
future with Oprah Winfrey I was raised
on a farm with my grandmother for the
first six years of my life I knew
somehow that my life would be different
and it would be better I never had a
clear-cut vision of what it was I would
be doing I just always felt somehow I
remember absolutely physically feeling
it at around four years old I remember
standing on the back porch was a
screened-in porch and my grandmother was
boiling clothes because you know during
the at that time we didn't have washing
machines until people would you know
physically boil clothes and a great big
iron pot she was boiling closing poking
them now and I was watching her from the
back porch and I was four years old and
I remember thinking my life won't be
like this my life won't be like this it
will be better and it wasn't from a
place of arrogance it was just a place
of knowing that things could be
different from me somehow I don't know
what made me think that rule number
three be courageous with Morgan Freeman
here's a stat from from your show and it
says the richest 85 people on this
planet have as much money as the poorest
3.5 billion yeah that's on the planet
however sex
it's not far off in America no it isn't
far off in America but we still and we
still here don't abandon the idea that
it isn't finite yeah it isn't finite if
you were born where were you born me
yeah
Baton Rouge Louisiana batteries General
Hospital there you know Louisiana I was
born in Memphis Tennessee had a long
haul from where I came from to here but
here we are right so proof is in the
proof of the pudding is in the eating
and here we sit at the dining table but
it's hard to when you say that to some
people because they say oh there you go
with a pull yourself up by the
bootstraps thing and you know you're
just being respectable not everybody can
do that look everybody can but it
doesn't courage courage is the key to
life itself there are a lot of people
who are born in situation if I survive
just I'll never get out of this so they
won't I say to people say well I would
like to have done so and so and so so
you could have done it so when I
couldn't get out of here man the bus
runs every day exactly right yeah
you exist if there if there if you can
conceive it in your mind if you can
think of it you can do that's a human
condition and we can imagine that we can
do it right and I think that the
condition of each individual human rule
number four don't make decisions based
off of money with Mellody Hobson do not
make any decisions based on money none
it's the worst way to make a decision
which I know is so hard to say I mean I
didn't grow up with any money and I know
so many of us are our families have a
lot at stake they put a lot into us made
a lot of sacrifices for us and you say
you don't have the luxury of doing that
but I actually think you do you will be
more successful if you
make decisions based upon what is going
to feed your soul make you feel value
valued validated you know have you
waking up in the morning and wasting to
work whatever it might be and I can tell
you after a short amount of time money
will not be enough at the end of the day
a bigger paycheck is another suit or
more real estate more square footage
that's what it comes down to you end up
with another room and a fuller closet
and after a while that's not going to do
it
rule number five choose to be great with
Chris Gardner we developed this concept
that we call spiritual genetics I mean
we all understand genetics you're going
to get your mom's eyes your dad's nose
nothing you can do about it
but the spirit of who you're going to
become as a person the soul of who
you're going to become as a man or a
woman
I believe you can choose I believe you
can choose you've read my book you know
I could have become my stepfather I
could have become another alcoholic
wife-beating child abusing illiterate
loser
and a lot of people would have said
we'll look where he's from he didn't
have a choice
well I did I chose to embrace the light
I saw my mom the light was greater and I
chose to embrace the light briefly how
the book came to be I didn't just sit
out one day and say let me write a
memoir I was not prepared to just sit
down and go through all these little
boxes of stuff that we all have in our
heads the mines were all stamped with
the same tag do not disturb it was not
my choice but I was getting an award one
night for fatherhood okay big a program
and the emcee was to keep the program
rolling and he kept citing all these
statistics and he kept saying the same
things over and over if you're from this
family
if you're from this house if you lived
in this environment this is who you're
gonna turn out to be none of the things
were good and I kept sitting there
saying to myself
version of that's BS that's BS to the
point that when I got up to the
microphone to give my award you know
what came out of my mouth I'm so glad I
said it because in a room full of a
thousand people so many people came up
to me afterwards I said thank you
because I'm from that house I'm from
that family I'm from that environment
just like you and I made a conscious
choice to go the other way
rule number six be around information
with Sean Combs if I was coming today I
would do whatever it would take for me
to get to information I think that no
matter what it could have been in the
times of Jesus before Jesus caveman
times it was about being around
information back in caveman times it was
about who knows how to make a fire cuz
my ass is cold and now it's like you
know who really knows who is successful
in this day and age and how they are
successful so I think that I think that
our educational system needs to be fixed
in a sense because you know a degree
means something to me but experience
kind of means more and a point of view
of where people want to go kind of me
more than somebody saying I have a
master's from Harvard or what no I need
to know are you ready to go to war with
me right
that's what I need to know rule number
seven become an expert with Robert F
Smith the most important thing I think
you can do as a young person so I'm
going to speak to a couple of different
groups here young person in our
community is to become an expert to be
skilled in whatever it is that that you
are desirous of pursuing and that takes
countless hours and in some cases is
outreach for knowledge and information
and in some cases it is building a
learning capability and to me there's no
substitute for that you know the gift of
gab there's no substitute for becoming
an expert and being the best at your
craft
and that's what I focused on so if you
are sitting in your organization
thinking about going to do something
else you need to make sure that you are
the best skilled in that organization
before you do that or you spot an
arbitrage in the market that you can
uniquely take advantage of over a long
period of time but the first thing is
you've got to have those skills I mean
either so you can say oh I'm gonna go
figure it out
but I think you can figure it out before
you leave and have a very specific
design in mind where you can take
advantage of that arbitrage and I like
to say not measured in years but
measured in decades okay and then one of
the most important things which I
learned in chemical engineering is we
have to keep the ignorant uninformed
don't tell everyone how to do it if you
spot that arbitrage go do it and then
build systems and barriers so that not
everyone can come into your marketplace
once they realize that you're making a
fortune in it okay right so I mean be
thoughtful about it you know people have
put barriers to us for hundreds of years
and they've been thoughtful about it
so be thoughtful about creating an
economic opportunity for yourself and
for your community where you can sustain
that advantage we do some things in our
communities that no one does and rule
number eight the last one before the
bonus clip is be willing to try with
Barack Obama I believe we can keep the
promise of our founder the idea that if
you're willing to work hard it doesn't
matter who you are or where you come
from or what you look like or where you
love it doesn't matter whether you're
black or white or Hispanic or Asian or
Native American or young
or rich or poor able disabled gay or
straight you can make it here in America
[Applause]
you
[Music]
now I've got a special bonus Gary
Vaynerchuk clip for you but before
getting to that I'd love to know what
did you think of this video what do you
think of this new series did you enjoy
it should we continue it or not do you
have suggestions for how we could
improve it I would love to hear from you
please leave it down in the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
- black privilege which I genuinely
believe that in a world that we live in
and by the way I believe in all those
privileges wealth white celebrity it's a
nice it's a better time to be black than
it was 30 40 50 60 70 80 years ago
especially when hip-hop culture there's
not a white kid the works a better media
that isn't affected by hip-hop Colo yeah
I mean black people have changed the
world I mean you know it's so funny uh
you know they talk about people co-opted
in our culture but you know you look at
a movie like get get out like they want
to co-opt our consciousness period they
want to co-opt our spirits and I just
feel like it's the spirit that is
permeating the whole planet like
everything starts and ends to me would
hip-hop culture like they still like to
use the term pop culture pop culture
just means popular with the most popular
culture right now
hip-hop really taught me that hip-hop
I'm 41 and I was really into hip-hop and
when I was in high school hip-hop was
really hardcore you got to be a gangster
II like guys as you guys know made up
their backstories to make it seem like
they came from tougher places because
you couldn't be accepted the way you can
now if you grew up in a you know I
always think about eight-mile the last
scene right Clarence his parents you
know like but it's interesting when when
when it changed in like after POC and
Biggie got killed and people like you
know like it's like let's talk more
about like and it was happening a little
bit before when it got into Champaign
and it got into like you know you know
polo shirts and like umbrellas Bentley
ready like when it come on it when it
got into a different thing
what it what it was like oh my god all
those kids thought that was cool and
then what I'll never forget it when I
saw a Lil Wayne start caring about
skateboarding I was like okay something
very weird is about to happen because
that yeah and you've seen it right like
it's just in a totally different place
raise your standard Apple at the core is
core value
is that we believe that people have
passion and change the way people now
one drop of myself work depends on your
acceptance to me I don't ever give up
I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
roses success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link the
description for details